انتقل الان الى اسماعيل الغول الموجود في
مستشفى الشفاء قبل قليل اسماعيل تابعنا
تقريرك الذي يظهر حجم الدمار الذي لحق
بمحيط المستشفى بعد استهداف شقه وا
استشهاد 15 شخصا هل من تفاصيل جديده يمكن
ان
تضيفها اذا ما اجملنا الغارات الاسرائيليه
فصباح هذا اليوم قصفت قوات الاحتلال منزل
عائله ابو عجوه الذي ارتقى به 15 شهيدا
بالاضافه الى قصف مسجد الصبره قصف مسجد
النور في منطقه حي الصبره ووقع هناك
اصابات بالاضافه الى ذلك القصف العنيف
والمتواصل في منطقه محيط مستشفى الشفاء
بالتحديد المناطق الجنوبيه الغربيه
لمستشفى الشفاء هذه المناطق التي تشهد
استهدافا من مدفعيه قوات الاحتلال
بالاضافه الى قصف عنيف من الطائرات
المسيره الاسرائيليه مما ادى ذلك الى وصول
العديد من الشهداء الى مجمع الشفاء الطبي
حتى هذه لحظات تتواصل الغرات على تلك
المنطقه دون معرفه ما هي العمليات
الاسرائيليه التي تقوم في تلك المنطقه
علما ان قوات الاحتلال تقدمت في المناطق
الجنوبيه الغربيه وهذه المنطقه تعتبر
منطقه مركزيه مطله على منطقه ميناء غزه
التي اعادت بها الحياه بعد انسحاب قوات
الاحتلال قبل ايام واستطاع بعض الصيادين
اصطياد بعض الاسماك من منطقه ميناء غزه
رغم قصب قوات الاحتلال لبعض الصيادين
واستشهاد بعض منهم لكن لا مفر ولا ملاذ
امام الصيادين الا ل يات لقمه العيش رغم
الموت من هذه المنطقه اما بالانتقال الى
المناطق الجنوبيه الشرقيه فهي منطقه حي
الزيتون ومنطقه حي الشجاعيه هذه المناطق
التي تشهد تقدما ايضا محدودا لقوات
الاحتلال ومواجهات ضاريه مع المقاومه
الفلسطينيه علما ان هذه المنطقه نتواصل
بها ايضا القصف العنيف ل مدفعيه قوات
الاحتلال وحتى هذه اللحظه لم نبلغ عن وقوع
اصابات او الشهداء عفوا في تلك المنطقه
على الرغم من القصف العنيف علما ان بعض
المناطق التي تقصف بها قوات احتلال تزامنا
مع تقدمها هي مناطق مخلاه بسبب القصف
العنيف اما بالانتقال الى منطقه حيي
التفاح والدرج هذه المنطقه التي تتمركز
بها قوات الاحتلال على جبل الريس وتحاول
التقدم منذ ايام ووقعت وفق ما اعلنت كتائب
القسام بعدد من الكمائن وفجرت عدد من
الاليات بمختلف الاسلحه سواء اسلحه
المضاده للدروع او المضاده للافراد التي
اعلنت عنها كتائب القسام حتى هذه اللحظه
يسمع هناك دوي انفجارات متواصله واشتباكات
متواصله ما بين في الفينه والاخرى على
الرغم من ايه محاوله الاحتلال التقدم من
المناطق الحدوديه علما ان ايضا منطقه
بالعوده الى منطقه حي الشجاعيه وقعت بها
عمليه لكتائب القسام واعلنت عنها كتائب
القسام على المناطق الشرقيه وهذه المنطقه
الحدوديه التي خرج منها احد عناصر القسام
من فتحه النفق ونفذ عمليه باستهداف دبابه
مركي فاه بقذائف 105 اما على المنطقه
الغربيه الشماليه في هذه منطقه حي الشيخ
رضوان وحيا النصر تشهد تمركز لقوات
الاحتلال وعدم وعد واي ولم نشهد اي تغير
ميداني على هذه المنطقه